just a quick note that our conversation
contains some
potty talk yes
grown-up potty filth mouth talk sorry
[Music]
christian i recently watched mrs
doubtfire which i hadn't seen in a long
time and christian i think you knew the
movie a little bit better than i did i'm
a student of mrs doubtfire yeah you love
yeah i love it robin williams plays that
character so well first of all that you
sort of start forgetting that mrs
doubtfire isn't a woman
if you watch it from that perspective it
goes from being a fun family comedy to
being like a dark
erotic lesbian thriller where this old
scottish woman becomes fixated on this
family in particular the mother of this
family and she is like nasty to this
innocent man to the suitor who is like
you can't ask for a better suit she'll
literally say things about his oh hey i
wonder if your little willy's going to
get cold and invert itself into your
body because
she throws fruit at him yeah it's so
unrealistic that at some point that guy
wouldn't be like hey mrs doubtfire why
don't you go [ __ ] off
it's enough
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
from wondering this is justin long and
you are listening to life is short life
could be a dream sweetheart
and i'm here with my brother christian
and you're listening to one of the first
if not the first it's the first day this
is our first day this is exciting this
is the first time you're ever
introducing yeah it's clear uh podcast
yes
that's probably so let's just iron out
the kings as we go
this is a weekly interview show we're
going to be talking to actors
musicians all sorts of people some
thinkers artists which is not to say
that actors don't think people from all
walks of life uh who have something to
say we're gonna try to get them to say
it into a microphone why the name life
is short well
uh we're getting older and time is
flying by so i just i want to find out
how other people find meaning in life
and how they use their precious time how
they make the most out of it most
importantly it's the pun for everyone
who doesn't understand the pun
uh let me spell it out justin long
life is short oh
you didn't you never you ever put that
together i didn't yeah i'm kidding i'm
mostly lucky because it's a pun it's a
nice reminder too it's a nice sentiment
to say regularly life is short we're all
getting older you're 40 now yeah not
good
we've been talking about mrs doubtfire
uh why because why not well yeah because
we are going to every episode we're
gonna begin no i'm kidding uh our guest
today is neil patrick harris neil has
dabbled in the world of drag he is a
tony award-winning actor for playing
hedwig he played hedwig and the angry
incredible musical neil and his husband
david have a documentary coming out
called wig which is all about wig stock
the cultural movement that's been
happening for many years in new york and
so neil's going to talk about that it
comes out on hbo in june if you don't
know who neil is he was a child actor on
doogiehouser md he also played barney
stinson on how i met your mother for all
nine seasons and he's hosted just about
every award show out there the emmys the
tonys the oscars he's also won awards
for hosting those shows
he also does a lot of broadway i hate
that expression you must be living under
a rock but i think it applies if you
don't know who neil is and if you are
living under a rock congrats on
listening to this how are you doing that
neil's one of the most playful
interesting curious people i've ever
known we've had a lot of fun times with
them yeah vegas adventures we've had you
gotta tell the story uh about
we were in vegas with neil once uh it
was the opening of some cirque du soleil
we share a love of cirque du soleil and
so we went to one of those openings with
him and and it was i think it was
halloween right he was dressed oh my god
yeah okay so
we're at this outdoor like rooftop party
it's halloween
and the sun has gone down
at one point i
went to the bathroom
a little drunk came back and i couldn't
find my friends i couldn't find the
people i came with and i'm looking all
around and i'm like oh god where are
they and finally
i see neil
dressed immaculately in his costume
and he and he sees me and he and he
approaches me really
really quickly with purpose with real
purpose he's about uh a foot and a half
away from me and he and we're shoulder
to shoulder and he looks at me he opens
his mouth as as wide as you can imagine
it and he
puts both of his hands into his mouth
and he with both fingers
starts aggressively
pulling out this
ribbon from his mouth and it's pulling
out and
and the more he does it the faster he
goes and it's going on for so long
pulling pulling pulling pulling i
remember glancing down and seeing this
little pile of ribbon
accumulating on the ground and he's just
looking at me staring into my eyes
pulling this ribbon out and i'm like
transfixed by it it probably went on for
like 40 seconds but it felt like an hour
oh 40 seconds of that one it felt like
an eternity
so he was finally done and right when he
finished he just closed his mouth and
walked away
so then
on top of already being lost and and
wondering where my friends were i was
like
now i need to tell the story to somebody
because if i don't tell it soon like no
one's going to believe me that this
weird thing just happened
he's like a magical person he's just so
kind of like present and curious he's
playful playful so i hope you enjoy uh
my conversation with neil after this
life could be a dream sweetheart
have we started is this happening uh are
you gonna wait and get a countdown okay
so i guess we've started
you were born in albuquerque uh both
your parents are lawyers
yes what you're the hesitation my mother
went to law school she um graduated from
law school they were both attorneys but
she stopped practicing and my dad
recently sort of retired um somebody
still kind of does some law work she
stopped when you were born when when she
knows no she's she went to law school
when we were like 10 oh 13 or something
oh my god i did three years of traveling
back and forth from albuquerque three
hours south to ruidoso where we lived
every weekend for three years so were
you going on auditions when you were
that young have you ever i was a kid i
didn't start acting in earnest until i
was i think 12 or 13.
i was a very precocious
kid in a super small town in new mexico
so
while i was in the adult episcopal choir
as a nine-year-old
and while i was in the band and the
choir and sort of took over and didn't
did as much as i could there was no
theater to speak of but that's an app
that's an avenue that most stars uh will
go through their episcopal choir
i've heard that countless hands yeah uh
the casting couch thing never stops yeah
wow
there it is yes
the choir director and the band director
both thought
that i should maybe go to a performing
arts high school so they brought up that
idea but that felt really strange
because we lived in this town so then
they said but there is new mexico state
university in las cruces and they have a
week-long theater program
and i went for a week and i got to go to
school and you loved it i got to stay in
the dorm room and learn how to play
freeze tag and do cold reading audition
classes and it was probably just to get
people to want to go to the college yeah
um but it was uh it was helmed by a man
named mark medoff playwright yes
children of a lesser god yes and who
recently passed away god rest his soul
and he had written this movie called
clara's heart
based on this david aunt king novel and
whoopi goldberg was going to star in it
and it was a warner brothers movie i
knew none of this but i was in the camp
and he thought i could be
the other protagonist in that movie so
he asked my parents after the camp was
done whether
they'd
feel comfortable with something like
that so they said sure but didn't tell
me wow he was kind of lying and then he
sent the script from warner brothers
one of those pictures and then they told
me about it i auditioned for the movie i
ended up getting the movie and so
suddenly i was in baltimore maryland
filming wow starring with bobby goldberg
in a movie so is that significant a part
yeah that was a whole lead in it and
whoopi i mean she's one of the most
famous whoopies there's will be pie
there will be cushion
and there's ruppy goldberg christian's
my favorite sure do you like the old
school one why do you blow up with your
mouth or do you like the one that
self-inflates or do you like the
elephant
i didn't know of the last of the latter
two so they have one that has sort of a
soft foam inside now so that you don't
have to take the flattened
rubber outside and then blow it back up
and then put it back under the chair
just sort of because there's foam inside
when you sit it still makes the no
kidding it just self inflates but now
they have the electronic ones where you
just push a button
and of course you know myriad of farts
oh really fart machine oh yeah i have it
on here i have a fart app of course so
that's kind of the wolfy cushion that's
true that's the new that's what the kids
are going to grow up with now vr's
whoopee cushion i just introduced my
nephew who's a year and a half to the
whoopee cushion and i and i really
[ __ ] up because i i popped it the
first time i sat on it so he's now i'm
so afraid that during his formative
years he's had a negative experience
first experience with the cushion he got
really scared he cried he did he welled
up yeah i mean he's a sensitive little
kid but the la and like if i turn him
off our jokes uh it would be like it
will never happen great just through the
armpit fart and then he'll be right back
into it yeah kids love that kids love
that i i mean it's
still funny you have a very playful i
would imagine you were an incredible dad
you and david uh you are a magician i
mean like yeah man i like magic you love
magic do you do that with your kids do
you
really
i think my kids would be my least
favorite audience why is that
because you're with them all the time
magic is super good when you can come in
to a group that doesn't know you right
and that's true they don't think you're
doing anything sneaky then you do
something amazing and they never see you
again like that's the best that's true
so it would also be a lot to live up to
you're around the mother if you if you
raise the bar too high it's a lot too
yeah don't pull a quarter out of your
kids either yeah that's right that's the
only thing you ask for for the next
three years yeah in 10 years you're
going to put like pull like 10 grand out
of there
um did you at the time was there a time
or do you now still struggle with
insecurities about performing when you
were doing that movie where did you ever
have that moments of what the [ __ ] am i
doing i guess if there were any
insecurities that i've had between then
and now which is ages i would
probably
chalk it up to
not feeling like i don't know i still
feel sometimes like i'm 12 or 13
trying to impress
high school seniors i think because my
life sort of took a big turn
around that age so i'm part of my brain
is still kind of there which is nice it
keeps me feeling youthful and you know i
went from clara's heart to some weird tv
movie things lonnie anderson
drowned me in the pool
in the movies
and then i got doogie hauser which was
which was i was 15 turning 16. you were
that young so that's yeah oh my god so
that i didn't go to college right so
yeah so from my formative you know
pre-puberty years on
there's been a bit of a tension at me
for a while it was like the attention i
didn't love yeah it was and what is that
and what form was that well because i
was known as doogie yeah so it was it
was kids who were two years older than
me who had gone through puberty who were
like pointing and laughing and calling
me that name it's also not intentionally
mean but it was you know i didn't want
to be known as someone else i was proud
to have worked on something but i didn't
need to be defined by that and yet i
didn't really have the anonymity to say
i'm going to be a guy liner god guy for
a year
you can't explore really you can't take
your new identities or explore different
yeah also of all the names to be known
as it's not like the character's name
was phil or mike
thunderbolt yeah something good yeah
yeah
thunderbolt house actually would have
been a really strong show yeah doogie is
such a as as it's like and it's iconic
but
what you've done since has more than
overshadowed that now doogie seems like
it's oh yes something you did
yeah it seems like a badge of honor more
than anything but that by design the
name was chosen by steven bochko to be a
young sounding name like skippy or right
because the whole premise of the show
was a young kid just an actual doctor
dealing with adult things so it was judy
hauser md so the title alone sort of
sold the show did you ever think about
oh you know i
i could do this i could be a doctor yeah
not really i was just always too
razzmatazz yeah it was like a lot of
jazz hands and yeah i really loved theme
parks going to st louis and going to six
flags and then i would go straight to
see all the shows right because i loved
when the sets would move and when the
same actors would have costume changes
that's sort of like the magic trick of
the theater so that always intrigued me
yeah and i didn't really want to just
sit for years in in college that makes
sense that question that i asked you
about would you ever consider being a
doctor i think that's remnants of
how i was introduced to you and i knew
you so well you're one of those people
when i met you i felt like i
knew you and yet i would say you're
quite different from that character
having known you now in life a little
bit um did people ever i mean people
must still i guess but but certainly at
the time it must have been frustrating
when people
weren't able to separate you from that
character i will say that when i was on
the tv show and it was a successful show
on an abc
network that was during a time when
there weren't a lot of other television
channels or options sure so you were
either
in tv or you were in motion pictures
right right it was not the crossover
right that there that exists now yeah
and so
being on tv in like my late teens
and looking over
the fence and seeing my p some of my
peers being in movies that seemed so
much more legitimate
and then there was a span of time when
the show was done
where that's that dynamic still existed
and since i not only had been on a tv
show and was familiar with it but had
that name sort of attached to it yeah it
was hard to get feature film
opportunities and so that was always
kind of the graspy and greener over in
you know in toby mcguire yeah but you're
right that is that is not that is an
unfair way it's a misleading way to
catch a question too to say
yeah because it because over the drama
yeah no no i don't know another thing
that sucks
that max casella
don't get me started oh by the way
mexican was my first
yeah my first uh my first um impression
i can only say that word i love max
casella he was the best he was the best
part of doogiehousermd yeah he was i
think seven or eight years older than i
was oh he was yeah but played much
younger so therefore his comedic timing
was stellar and i just felt bad for him
more than myself
because i was doogie and
and got that a lot but i played him and
i was kind of the
nucleus of the show and i it must have
been complicated for him post show
because he still looked very much like
vinnie yes and he probably got a little
like a lot of hey vinnie where's doogie
and he was probably over that he must
[ __ ] have hated me for a decade i
don't know where he didn't know where he
is stop it
hey i'm not crawling through your window
back away
but and you are now as was he you are
known
now you have a recognizable face how
does that
what were the bonuses of that and what
were the limits
yeah yeah i could get into uh clubs
really yeah in l.a without any kind of
fake id or anything and did you do that
it would i did yeah
yeah i would flirt with drew barrymore's
mom oh really you flirted with jade yeah
how does that work
to get into the club oh yes
are you being serious super serious no
kidding yeah so i did way more partying
when i was 19 and 20 then i and i had a
fake id
my friend chuck got me a good fake id
over in in downtown l.a it was like 50
bucks very exciting i didn't need it
because i was getting on the tv show and
i think it was it's like when webster
would come in you know emanuel lewis
would be in the corner it was like yeah
there's right there's neil patrick
harris over in that side
who would let me in to think i i i
didn't look like i was 21 until i was
about 34. right yeah you were young i
was a young looking kid what was your
fake id name no it's my own name oh yeah
it was thunderbolt and harry potter
uh md no so i did a lot of drinking and
a lot of
of like
young hollywood partying and then you
wound up you know then you're in there
and it was super loud and you saw these
same [ __ ] people yesterday yeah what
was the craziest thing you saw i mean
was there ever a night where you were
like oh my god i'll never forget this
i'm glad i did this tonight there were
sexual escapades that were fun in that
world that you witnessed that was a part
of that you were part of yeah i might
myself and
and one two
three four of us
all fooled around simultaneously with
the mother of another friend of ours
okay
and so while that while that was
happening which was really kind of
bizarre then the
uh her hotel room door opened up and
then her girlfriend
came in
and she started screaming at us
because we were with her
girlfriend who was our friend's mom so
this is nev campbell
and
shannon elizabeth no but it was it was
that time it was that time it was a fun
time at this time are you
again a different time but are you
paranoid about being outed for your
sexuality i mean are you worried about
that at this time no i was so no i was
worried at that time more about
being sort of typecast yeah i was
interested in oh
and i think i'm i'm very happy that i
worked early on that show because it
sort of
gave me a
lifelong um
fuel to keep diversifying myself yeah
which i think is a valuable career
thing to do and and rare to be able to
do it i just didn't want to be in tv
right as i said before i wanted to be a
movie so then i and so then i was done
with tv wasn't getting into movies and i
loved the theater yeah so i went and did
more theater stuff and then i and so
that was a very cool thing an entrance
into that and then i did started then
doing movies and then the hosting stuff
so i've been sort of building lots of
i've been plate spinning you just and
and these things kept building because i
mean i think but you want to get to the
sex you want to get to the jobs yeah
who was your first uh
which cast member of party of five was
your favorite person to
make out uh when you're getting into
plays was that because um
i mean obviously you you have a talent
but how did you build that empire how
did you when i did clara's heart they
all got to go to jamaica at the end of
the movie because part of it was filmed
in jamaica and my character wasn't in
the jamaica scenes so they were all
excited to go to jamaica the producer
marty elfont lovely guy instead since
they were going to jamaica flew my
parents myself to new york city
and so we got to go on our own little
trip which was just very sweet of them
and we saw les miserables on the big
broadway and that was a show that i knew
very well because back in that in in
that camp i went to for a week yeah i
was introduced to the soundtrack of les
mis and then i saw that show and i just
couldn't believe that that many talented
people could be on the stage that moved
in a circle and this giant barricade
would appear yeah it was overwhelming i
remember that and i just loved
that that happened
six times nights a week yeah and that it
and i just wanted to do that so i would
come
every hiatus period that we had
uh with my extra money because i was on
a tv show and i would come to new york
and i would see 12 shows in 10 days and
then i'd go back were you salivating to
get out there and do that dying to do
that yeah yeah and but then when the
show was done i realized that that one
of the drawbacks of doing a television
show
for more than a couple years at least a
single camera one where it's filmed like
a movie is that you you learn how to not
move at all really well
because if you move left and go sit in
the chair they have to light a bigger
part of the room and so i got really
good at sort of walking into a room and
walking to my mark without looking down
and then standing perfectly still yeah
so the show was done and i was like what
do i do for my arms yeah how am i
supposed to like sit that's interesting
yeah put my hands in my pocket behind my
back like it was very kind of awkward
that's why i did the theater as well
because i thought
that's full body do you watch reality
shows you ever watched like the bachelor
not the romantical ones
survivory ones there's this one called
90 day fiance
it's incredible i i won't go on about it
time is limited but
it's interesting to watch self-conscious
people who aren't used to being on
camera do what they do with their hands
and and this guy
was you know that like kind of nerdy
thing where they stick just their
fingers in their pockets sure and the
rest of their hand you're sort of
splaying out yes and it's sort of like
hanging by the side and but you there's
that self-consciousness that i'm still
that way uh on on carpets on step and
repeats when you're at the premiere of
absolutely what do you do if you're
wearing a suit what are you doing uh
pockets i'm i'm committed to my pockets
with the suit you have the suit jacket
on right so that means that the suit
jacket's built like bunched up i gotta
tell you just making me so it's so
comforting to know that this is
something that goes through your mind
too that you struggle with oh that's so
i would never have guessed i started
doing the hand like the light hand clasp
and then maybe like adjusting like my
cuffs i just yeah oh you do maybe i'm
i'm just mid buttoning the jacket right
but when you're doing that it's it's to
do something right it's just to keep my
hands busy yeah oh my uh or pointing
pretending you see somebody ever do that
one look at that
over there yeah or the double fingers
like a gun
i'm glad
i've never done that well they yell at
you and they say give me a piece they're
willing to like things sign peace signs
give you a piece give me a smile uh
that's so good to know that you do that
um when was cabaret and how how
important was that doing that role um
and cabaret was super great so cabaret
ran on broadway and alan [ __ ] did it
initially at studio 54 yeah that they
had
the roundabout had taken over that
property so studio 54 already came with
this great horny vibe yeah and then that
show was super randy and and exciting
and won all the tonys and it was
it was very awesome i had done rent
before that i was in the first speaking
of 45 second national tour of rent that
did la jolla and then los angeles so i
sort of liked alt
theater yeah i had bleached my hair
blonde and was you know wearing thrift
store clothes and stuff cowboy been
running for a bit and they asked if i
wanted to be the mc
so i replaced the much much sought after
raul esparza
and i did it for a while i did it with
deborah gibson
and i did it with molly ringwald before
that that's right i don't think that you
could do that show today because it was
there were very few polls post me too a
very it was a very pre me too yeah
yeah but it was great because i lived in
new york i was able now to be anonymous
because in new york no one gives a [ __ ]
about what you're thinking about or
doing at all i got to be the mc and in
in being the mc in cabaret
i colored my hair
jet black like a blue black my armpits
were dyed black my happy trail i saw it
you were amazing
it was very androgynous yeah and very
sexual yeah so you could do at the mc
especially anything like you could just
and the and the the ensemble were or
musicians and you could i could
literally just walk around and sit on
someone's lap in the audience wow and
like grab their tits yeah and then like
go up and walk around and like
sort of give guy a hand job while they
suck on his neck while he's playing a
saxophone and then not and then push him
away it's the sound of music
no but truly and i had never in my life
a uh been in a role that would allow
that sure b i never thought of myself as
a person who would be allowed that but
with that comes sort of a sexual
swag ernie swagger that you have to own
because if you act shocked at what
you're doing and that doesn't that
doesn't isn't and they'll read and
they'll see through it i mean i would
imagine i would imagine an audience
especially like a broadway like post
allen coming they they they will know if
you're not owning it the best thing
about
doing theater is that
is that you can sort of fake it but
you're doing it in repetition enough
times that you really like it to do yeah
so it's like hedwig
i did uh which was uh in complete drag i
mean transgender drag yeah and i had
never ever even walked in heels before i
did that so i had to then not only be
confident as a woman but like well past
insecurities of it because she was old
and had been doing that for years and
years so that was that was the tricky
acting how did you do that how did you
literally just walk around you just got
i mean did you we befriended willem
belly who was a drag
rupaul's drag race all-star was on
season two got kicked off
he's still amazing and a friend
and
that was after when how i met your
mother was ending and we just went in
the rehearsal room and he brought some
wigs and heels and taught me how to walk
them it's tricky now now these are also
parts that kind of transcend
specific type of sexuality heterosexual
homosexuality was there ever a concern
that as there may have been after dookie
houser i'm going to be seen in this
light i'm now going to be seen in this
light i think i was more afraid of that
when that was
worth being afraid of which was i think
four or five years before okay like yeah
ellen coming out on tv this is now who
you are there was a big glass ceiling
that no one had broken through yeah and
so everyone i think was concerned that
it may affect future job opportunities
and back then it probably did yeah in
the same way that being on tv meant that
you didn't get to be in movies totally
um
so i think i was kind of just guarded as
a performer because i didn't want to
commit too much and accidentally reveal
too much yeah yeah so i had this sort of
intrinsic um internalized kind of
homophobia about what it meant if your
legs were crossed this way versus this
way or how people would take it if you
were sitting and your wrist was
not perfectly straight i mean i just
spent a lot of time processing all of
that so getting to play something that
was
hyper-sexual was great and my coming out
happened during how i met your mother
where you're playing this very i mean
he's he's such a he is a super player
yeah yeah yeah straight but fun and like
down with anything and made out with 80
year olds and dogs very sexual very
hyper-sexualized and this is what this
is how um so much of america is now
absorbing you in this capacity they're
seeing this character and so uh i think
that
the bro totally you're you still i mean
i see you sometimes that those heineken
commercials are like
you're that's a bro kind of like
you know demographic that uh is meant
that i was very pleased that i was doing
i was i was uh accepted by that
demographic yeah when all of the
the coming out happens well i think it
also did a lot for the gay community i
think it was a a huge thing that that
happened to coincide that role
uh the timing of your coming out because
you know it's like it i think it
probably dispelled a lot of myths about
what gay performers are uh here you are
convincingly playing this kind of guy to
a mass audience and so you know it
didn't really matter i mean that's what
it i think it probably said to a lot of
people the fun thing about having done
dmc in cabaret where he was
intentionally like omnisexual yeah the
fun thing about being
super horny and harold and kumar the fun
thing about being
nasty as hedvig and super
bro guy horny
um wing man in how i met your mother is
that what i think is fun
is just being flirty yeah like i feel
like everyone likes to be flirty sure
and to be flirted do you miss being able
to do that i mean you say that camera
it's amazing you know but i'm saying
that after i still do it a ton but
something like cabaret you say like you
can and i agree with you i don't think
you can do that right now i think that
my camera was nasty just because i
looked crazy so i could be on the subway
and people were kind of scared of me so
there's a danger element to it sure but
what i think is fun now is that
i i think that most comfortable straight
guys are flattered when a gay guy
i'm not saying flirts with him in a way
that like trying to like blow him in a
bathroom stall or something but saying
that they're handsome yeah or
complimenting them feels good like i
love telling women that their bodies
look great or that they look great
bradley cooper i want to hear that you
know what i mean i don't think they're
going to say oh
thanks but you're gay so i'm not going
to take it yeah i don't internalize in a
weird way they almost i prefer
compliments from gay men
yeah uh you know what you're talking
about but bradley cooper bradley does
that more better than anyone else say
god buddy you look so good you know and
i i find myself getting a little flush
like no perhaps
please our christian stars yeah yeah do
you think so i really take it to heart
um i didn't really enjoy the fluidity of
it and if there's anything i can do as
as uh as someone in the sort of lgbtq uh
world in an agenda way
it would be someone who
lives by example and is very i try to be
very uh covert in the acceptance that i
can create it's not something that i
would boast about but it's something
that i acknowledge i get to go every
year to disney world and uh do something
called the candlelight processional
where it's for the holidays they have a
celebrity come to epcot center to the
american pavilion
and they read the story of jesus at a
pulpit in front of a full orchestra the
disney choir the voices of liberty and
and four children's choir so there's
there's probably
250 people on stage
and people and there's they and they do
it three times a night and people queue
up for hours no kidding and it's free
but you have to queue up for it and i've
done it for like 11 years
and i and it it's not lost on me
that i get to
start the show with some opening remarks
and i can talk about what i did today
with my husband and my kids yeah yeah
and
that doesn't freak people out too much
and then i tell the story of jesus and
the purpose of jesus and so i'm not it's
not heavy-handed i'm not i'm not trying
to be ironic about it but i'm very
appreciative that
i'm in a unique weird opportunity
sometimes to
um
potentially create conflict within
people who
are black and white absolutely to say
well he as much as i think he's a
sodomite and a sinner and they're all
going to go to hell really entertaining
he was really good telling the story of
jesus like i remember i remember this
for the rest of my life it's too bad in
the afterlife i won't be able to watch
him perform he'll be riding in hell
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge watching low
budget made for tv holiday movies the
all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wondering plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again have you ever played
anyone super gay yeah yeah quite in fact
i was just going to say i i just talked
to a journalist about this i was
about a play that i had just done um and
he said you know where i was playing a
real toxic male i mean i had the epitome
of toxic masks
it's called do you feel anger at the
vineyard and this guy was it was an
absurdist thing about male female
dynamics in the workplace and i was
playing guy who was really just like a
primate almost i mean he was like he
acted purely on id and
wanted
you know a version of what you got to do
in cabaret nice uh grabbing grabbing
tits and jerking guys off i wish i'd you
know wait you were gay and no no no no
he was just in terms of overt sexuality
just like grabbing um but i was talking
to this journalist about um
what are those rules now i mean because
we're redefining these things and we're
kind of drawing certain boundaries that
we hadn't established before
what do you think the rules are in terms
of or should there be in terms of
straight actors playing gay men gay
actors playing you know uh he had
suggested that now it might not be as
cool
for a straight actor to play a gay role
and i wondered it's a tricky
conversation for sure yeah i think that
all should be allowed yeah the gay
community will eat themselves alive
because
they like to talk shade yeah about their
you know about their own and so that's
its own tricky thing because
if a straight guy plays a gay guy then
certain people will be offended well
there's tons of gay guys that aren't
getting rules so why not give that to a
gay guy right what then like straight
guy he's not allowed to ever play a gay
party i know it starts to unravel a
little bit i'm a i'm a big fan of the
lack of rigidity
so yeah yeah the the you know i'm very
appreciative that we live in a world now
where the fluidity of
the scale
is not so uh black and white so yeah
that our kids are eight years old and
growing up in
new york city with all kinds of
diversity around them at school in their
home life
and therefore
we don't have to say no you need to
write with dolls
you need to play with this yeah i'm
super happy with all i'm happy with
their happiness yeah yeah so if uh if a
straight guy is nailing a part and
really wants to do this and go for it
that'd be great and be hypocritical for
you who played a man with a one-inch
penis with common knowledge you have an
11-inch penis uh that's common knowledge
well it's it is for those that were
crying about it you know yeah
yeah i know the one inch uh dick acting
community was very upset about some of
them your performance um you when you
you uh you talked a little bit about it
having to learn how to walk like a woman
i saw you in that part and was
transformative and hyper sexual like
like an aggressive like in your face
sexuality that was
palpable is that the part where we make
out yeah yeah well this is right before
we make out okay um i'm leading up to
the making i'm gonna get a listerman
strip um
you are now this is a great segue for um
uh a show that that i will be pleasuring
myself too
uh
you you and david are are
producing a documentary about wig stock
you could talk a little bit about that
it's called wig it's closing the tribeca
film festival it's very exciting so wig
stock is uh
is a drag festival that was started
25 years ago or something by an amazing
drag queen named the lady bunny a drag
performer with early rupaul and she was
performing at the pyramid club and stuff
and they decided hey it's three o'clock
in the morning we're all wasted let's go
to thompson square park where they have
this sort of outdoor amphitheater kind
of vibe and we'll just we'll just put on
a show and then it it caught on and they
started doing them every year and and it
suddenly became a real outlet for drag
and counter culture back in the 20 years
ago
early 90s and then thousands of people
were seeing it and they did it up until
uh 2000
uh right when the twin towers fell and
it was supposed they were supposed to do
one that year but the vibe wasn't right
and so she just kind of stopped
david lady husband
uh we were watching drag race because
we're fans of that show and david said
why don't they do wig stock anymore and
i said that's a fantastic question this
would be a this would be a great time to
do it acceptance has never been higher
in the drag world
and and he said we should do it and i
said do you know lady bunny he said no
we can find her and so he reached out to
bonnie
bunny didn't have a good reason why she
had stopped doing it and so we joined we
got
her to say yes and then cut to a year
and a half later of us you know figuring
it out but we did it at the top of um
south street seaport
over memorial day
and it was unbelievable it was eight
hours of drag performances
you and you hosted it no bunny hosted it
i did hedwig i revived
it and uh in the later part of the show
but it was eight hours it was 50 plus
performers and that the documentary is
about you guys putting it back together
it's it's two things so it's about the
recreation of and the the history of of
wig stock and what it meant then when it
started and then what it has become now
and then we cross that with sort of what
the drag gay culture is on the east
coast now because now it's more gender
fluid there's a lot of you know
trans-positive stuff that's happening
with it we follow a
woman named charlene incarnate who's
fully trans and part of her act is
dancing and then taking her clothes off
and you see her naked breasts and also
her
penis yeah and uh and it's kind of
empowering and strange but amazing uh
and so it sort of follows that culture
of of a younger
the younger group and the older brigade
coming together i don't know i just
always loved having done hedwig i always
thought
as much as i love rupaul's drag race and
i still watch it yeah
watched it last night as a matter of
fact um
i i recognized and david was very smart
in saying this that we only see them
performing when they're about to be
kicked off the show
lip sync for your life
and they're only singing a song that's
been chosen for them by the producers
and so they're singing a song that's
chosen for them so they're really not
getting to showcase what they do best
and i thought no you know what we should
film this and it should we should do a
documentary of it and i want to do this
in a place in a way that these queens
who are all individually so
fascinating and fabulous and filled with
ferocity a ferociousness and a power and
yet kind of tragic and
ratchet and beat up at the same time
just by design shaving their yeah
in order to put on pancake makeup
covering their their hairy eyebrows
to make themselves look more i want them
to be recognized doing what they do best
like like i want to show i want them to
have their elements in their element
living and i think documenting that
which we did where you're seeing people
in front of thousands now in a gorgeous
setting outside like
lip syncing or singing and living and
sweating i don't know i just thought
yeah the reason the pores attention must
be paid
assassins having done it this is the
part you played yeah also brilliant but
i so i just and i'm really pleased with
the with the uh
yes queen
yeah have you ever done drag
the closest i came was i did a little
part in the breakup where i wore heels
and a wig kind of like a fabulous long
but where are you supposed to be no he
was kind of uncomfortable in the walk
and now he was he was supposed to be
comfortable which is why i shot most of
my stuff sitting down
because it really was difficult i i was
very difficult i i i saw hedwig shortly
after i did that and i remember
i realized really having an appreciation
for how difficult that must have been
because it is [ __ ] hard i see i still
see when i see women walking in high
heels i
i'm only walking in high heels but i
think everyone has their own gazelle
inner intrinsic
homophobia about themselves yeah huh but
not everyone that's that's not true not
accurate but i think a majority many
people guys
feel like if they put on heels and they
[ __ ] a hip and then they drop a shoulder
and they kind of sass themselves up that
if they're if they're too good at it
if they see that walk too well too fast
that it might
mean something and if they're really
gawky and uncomfortable it might mean
something and i meant something to me
yeah i'm 100 gay yeah but even doing
that even when i was walking and
learning how to do it i was sweating and
so like clammy because your body wasn't
useless my body was not okay with it's
almost like your body is homophobic yes
yeah it was very crazy and i had to get
well past that funny it hasn't been an
issue for me
really my body was like this is this is
natural this is what you're supposed to
be
uh yeah
but
but i um but i know i think that is true
of a lot of men that that if they're you
know there's that phrase no homo you
don't hear about anymore but like yo no
homo bro but i hear that before allah
that's prefaced a lot of compliments not
that i get paid a lot of compliments but
when guys say you know i want to can we
take a picture like i like that thing
you did it's it often prefaced with hate
no homo but can we take a photo
that's such a weird thing to say and
that's their ownism exactly why she
cares that's kind of fun about being gay
and having the same guy asked me for a
picture they don't say no homo because
they don't feel like offensive but but
you probably feel them putting on like
yo bro you know there may be pushing a
little bit about this is not
just so there's nothing misleading about
this you know i can't i don't get that
very often i'm i'm very uh appreciative
of
of being raised and becoming an adult in
the age that i have yeah yeah i'm glad i
was born in 73. yeah i'm glad that i'm
glad that we're at a place in our world
now where people feel less obliged to be
only known as a singular thing yes and
i've met a lot of really really alpha
male straight guys that really want to
take a selfie with me knowing that i'm
gay and being super cool not having to
like say hi to my girlfriend exactly
yeah that's funny that's interesting i
mean that's good that's great and in
fact so many hand jobs i bet i bet i
mean that's why you do it countless
that's why you got into this that's why
that weak and you know you can count
them on one hand if you if you catch the
comedy
oh i do
oh comedy is not lost here uh i mean it
is for the most part um speaking of
comedy
uh there's that enough gay talk for you
well no you know in fact i wanted to
tell you uh uh do you speaking of um
the drag circuit uh is drag queens
inappropriate words still drag queen
queen yeah queen's great queen is great
uh
i mean i say like
yeah like no you're an adorable dragon
for a living but i think queen did i
remember that bar on first and first uh
called uh
waikiki wallies no uh waikiki wales was
like a tiki bar right next door to that
um uh karaoke drag bar called lucky
changs oh cool lucky chang's and the
first time i ever said i was an actor
out loud was at lucky chang's we would
go it's cool you get all liquored up uh
you'd have a zombie one of those like
drinks they pour all the everything into
the flaming and uh and then you'd go
through the kitchen to lucky changs and
um i i was doing a show with ed the show
and that nice you did an episode of uh
and and we were all there and we hadn't
been on the air yet and the hostess for
the show was anita cocktail
and she was just surly and fierce and i
signed up and i went up to sing and she
goes you're cute honey what's your name
and i said it's justin she goes and what
do you do for a living and i said
well and i looked at my cast mates and i
was like i'm an actor and she goes
so am i dear i'm an actress what
restaurant do you work at and i said
well you know i don't work at a
restaurant anymore i'm actually an actor
just an actor and she goes
yeah and where do you where else do you
work and i said i i i got really nervous
and she said you know what i have a
friend who refuses to say that he he's
an actor and he refuses to say what the
restaurant works at and i'm an actress
and i work here and i'm proud of it and
you should be too and she tossed me the
microphone oh that's a great
introduction yeah and i just get a did
you
just he is a friend
so he's been just staring daggers at me
um but that that was my introduction to
the new york city's drag
community but i want to be reintroduced
uh and actually the documentary is in
june right wig is in june um do you mind
if we do some really quick questions
i don't but i have a question for you in
this sort of in the yeah please gay uh
fluidity question and it's what
something i've been asking a lot of
straight guys oh yeah i'm very confused
by it yeah yeah please
so you like uh blow jobs you like
getting receiving a [ __ ] fans of the
show will know how yes that that is very
true i would assume that would be the
case because you have an audi
and when you have an audi instead of an
innie it seems like you just want to put
it places i'm guessing yeah i do i like
putting it places warm places even
better right i like warm places warm uh
humid places
so
given that a cleanliness is assumed yeah
do you like to have a lot of tongue down
on your butt
tongue on the butt like finger in the
blood well well in the butt well that
assumption is um that's a big assumption
from me because i ass
yes go on um because i don't know if i
ever feel that clean i'm clean enough to
really be comfortable with with a tongue
in your blood um oh wait wait wait hold
on one second hey uh mom
uh
grandma grandma jody turn this off now
um i
maybe post shout out maybe if i were
like gay world i i just assumed because
you do a lot of math you do a lot of
take you do a lot of maintenance down
there you take care of myself sure you
got a manscape you got to look your best
i don't
do as much that's disrespectful
yeah i'm surprised that with straight
guys it's that you know yes you can go
this far
a couple more centimeters it's right
there's a real tank threshold with the
straight guns the taint of gibraltar
um yeah i mean why would you you're
right i mean it doesn't really make as
much sense except the ass is not a focal
point in my
you know in that interesting things it's
not just not a focal point wait but what
was your question about that about why
i'm just confused as to why why when
you're enjoying something physically
that's pleasurable
um why if if you like someone down that
far why limit yourself well then it
feels like it's almost homophobic in its
own way like i like that too much what
does that mean something i'm not i'm not
saying that you don't feel that way no
i was surprised i was having a
conversation with somebody else about
that i was like really that's
interesting you're right now you've
given me food for uh do you want me to
pause for like three seconds so we can
when that gets edited out you can then
start with your questions again i think
that's interesting life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
okay quick questions if you could give
20 year old neil really solid advice you
sit him down for like 30 seconds what
would you say
i would tell him that the decisions that
he would make that
he was most concerned about uh had
little consequence as long as he made
them uh in a thoughtful
way
i was very concerned about
what other people would think yeah in
life the moral of the story for me is to
leave a wake behind you that is as small
as possible yeah it's not like you have
to be super nice no no i don't know what
you mean but if you don't like something
you don't have to say that you like it
all the time you know you don't want to
have ill intentions as long as you're
authentic i feel like you can pretty
much do
whatever you want to do i'm still
learning that and i and i look back at
some of the time that i've wasted in
indulging in in that behavior and i
really regret it and i you know i've
been thinking about the name of the show
is life is short and i think about how
best to use this time the precious time
that we have left and and i think that's
a really that's such a great lesson
for teenagers that want to make it out
with the girl or the guy that they're
with yeah you know you you don't just
start making out with someone because
they could be really
upset by that yeah but you can ask them
yeah yeah and employ a little empathy
sure and just inject a little bit um
what is your most commonly used emoji on
your phone
oh probably the uh the rose emoji my
mother and i when we text each other
always end with a double rows or
multiple roses it's just like our sort
of thing
i also like the um
the eggplant and the sugar
water drops and you get the cherries in
front of that and you get the whole
package or a peach
or a peach yeah depending on yeah or
they're just a nice face after the water
drops oh depending on what you want yeah
there's also yeah there's this guy
eggplant and then the three water drops
and then there's sort of the the smiley
face but it's like dripping down the
side of the mouth that's the trifecta
the facial emoji facial emoji
or this one
[Music]
um
uh if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
oh wow that's a really cool question can
i ask your intention behind the question
um i j yeah i think is it sports do you
like to play or d how would you make the
most money how do you see your fantasy
self in in an athletic in a in a
physical way i suppose i would probably
be a gymnast
ah yeah or um or a diver or something
yeah yeah was greg louganis a moment for
you was that somebody that you saw and
we were like i remember that he was one
of the first gay figures that i remember
i just remember him hitting hands and on
the uh yeah on the board and that being
so terrible but he's so impressive my
take away from greg louganis and i've
never really
met him but it seemed that he was really
concerned about about being public about
his own life yeah it seemed that that
and i and i can't speak to the sports
world at all and i can only imagine that
back then that would have been a big
deal even more than acting but i
remember when i think of him i remember
it feeling conflicted as if he didn't
want to have to say it and once he i
don't know that yeah huh do you smoke do
you are you a stoner are you you're
you're you're you're you're words i'm
loving the the edibles and the vaping
i'm not a big bong joint kind of guy
because if i smoke too much pot then i'm
in so that i'm insecure and i'm not
sharp and i kind of like improving
dialogue yeah like
i think that's fun yeah yeah so i i tend
to smoke pot by myself yeah when
everyone's gone to sleep i have like
things i need to fix or build or put
together
so you get snacky and when you do get
snacky if you do what what do you what's
your go-to uh reese's peanut butter cups
all day all day and now reese's pieces
you need to the chocolate with it no the
very specific reese's peanut butter cup
straight away the reese's eggs are good
the christmas trees are are excellent
yeah but any like chunky or with pieces
in them or white chocolate not so much
okay um i will probably eat six or seven
at night no [ __ ] i did last night really
really and then i and then the next day
i'll say this is ridiculous man you're
in good shape yeah you are you're i go
to the gym and i and i and i have
children and then at night i will
sit and watch game of thrones and i will
i will like bring with me but isn't that
important seven or eight reese's peanut
butter cups and i will eat them all
right don't you need that don't you need
that balance i mean wouldn't it wouldn't
like that's life is it's a great part or
nacho cheese doritos those are really
really so good what's yours see i prefer
cool ranch but the nacho breath issue
with the cool ranch
yeah they do have kind of a strange
uh pizza flavor goldfish i'll just tear
through really or peppery form chess men
those butter cookies those are very
christ
favorite movie of all time
but i know you love willy wonka i was a
clue
really no martin maul
yeah wow um i love
there's a magical element to that right
isn't there like a sort of a victorian
i've always been a fan of um of
improvised comedy so guffman
um and i've always loved the murder
mystery my mom grew up with uh agatha
christie and every one of those so i i'm
a big fan of murder mystery tropes and i
love immersive theater stuff and i'm a
big fan when i'm making content of
having it be a little off structure i
love sleep no more i love cirque du
soleil yes i love the magic castle yeah
so clue the movie had three different
endings that you could go to see in the
80s and you didn't know it would say
ending a or ending b or ending c and you
would have to go see the movie three
times to see you know all three of the
multiple endings and it was absolutely
hilarious have you done a murder me have
you done something like that uh well as
a matter of fact i am in early early
stuff i uh with unintentional
elizabeth banks's company oh um
brownstone we're working on i'm going to
be writing and directing a murder
mystery improv comedy movie the untitled
sounding project the title is murder
mystery manor murder oh wow with an
exclamation point my oh my
um you'll get a call i'm excited for
that to be in it uh this what your
favorite muppet
oh man
kermit yeah i mean he's the one i relate
to the most it seems like an easy answer
and i know a lot of them up it's gonzo's
great fozzie's comedy's hilarious
piggy piggy of course somebody is
awesome and just such a performer uh
stuff was really
brilliant what about bob dirty rotten
scoundrel i love him
oh i have a good one for you
is it super powerful yeah x-ray vision
are super hearing
whoo i'd go x-ray vision i'll tell you
why yeah because i'd be re i'd i would
go into the insecure place with the
super hearing i don't want to hear [ __ ]
about myself exactly so you don't really
do you read reviews do you look at it i
do i read all of it you do i do
well i posted the oscars and yeah and
and that was a really exciting time and
an exciting night and then it was met
with almost uniformly negative response
and and that
was it was an intriguing divide for me
because i felt like it was going well
it's funny i don't i remember it i
thought the opposite after it was done i
just i went and read everything that
everyone said and it was really bad
which i think happens in the oscars but
because of that i just don't want to go
i want to i want that experience to live
on in my mind it's a positive one of
course but that said i think it's for me
it's important to have the information
and be able to process it you know if
you're around too much there's like over
saturation yeah like probably with the
apple commercials totally people [ __ ]
like annoyed by marshalls yeah but not
annoyed by him but then at what point is
it of course and we get it he's the mac
he's the best and then suddenly you're
not sure totally but i'd rather have the
information and then be able to say to
myself okay yeah people are not gonna
like it people are gonna like it but now
i sort of sort of know where i stand
within it you're lucky you're better out
of superpower i would be able to stop
time and move freely within it i think
it's the best one oh yeah and if you
could stop time in your own life or if
you could go back back to the future
style you had a delorean you hit 88
miles per hour
where do you go
ah in my own life yeah anyway yeah yeah
uh well both i'm curious about anywhere
in my anywhere i'd go to a turn of the
century probably 1900
new york
maybe like ragtime kind of yeah with one
of those
old-time magicians if you if you could
be one age for the rest of your life 45
years old
my exact year right now really i feel
like i'm in my best physical shape it's
so good i spent a lot of time and i
think it was because of the scrutiny
when i was younger yeah or the um the
the self-imposed
the idea of scrutiny from others yeah
thinking that people were watching me
when that really probably weren't well
i'm sure they may have that it's
understandable and so if even one did i
would probably have thought oh that
they're they're there see people are
watching i've gone to a crowded club
with you i've had the experience of
being in your wake behind david
christian and i were walking behind you
guys and the heads that were turning
were
unlike nothing i'd had seen up until
that point
yeah vegas is crazy yeah vegas is weird
for some reason i get recognized a lot
in las vegas i don't know why it seems
like people watch that show but anyway
because of that um i've i've i've still
been um conscious of my posture
conscious of like feeling
complete in in my own skin yeah you
mentioned as of recently now and i think
being a dad has a lot to do with that
because
you're less narcissistic you're more
living for somebody else yeah and you're
observing them i feel like my posture is
better my my flexibility is better when
i'm at stasis yeah and i'm just not
thinking about it right uh how how am i
existing physically yeah because even
still like when i get um
one of the things i hate is saying like
too many times and i realize that i'm
saying it a lot so i apologize
i i recognize that
in stasis i'll have
not like hunched over
yeah and
and and then and so i spend a lot of
time like correcting my own posture not
has nothing to do with straight or gay
or yeah or or masculinity or anything
it's just
i don't want to be yeah
i'm like one of the guys i'm like the
middle of the evolution you know
evolutionary man like i'm like the third
guy in who's but then people say you
have good posture neal and then i i'm
i'm i think that's fantastic but i don't
feel like i do that's so i guess now at
45 i feel more in control of who i am i
really want to be a cirque du soleil
performer well we i mean we're a sleep
no more performer i've fantasized about
doing sleep no more for a couple months
you could my god you have to take takes
three weeks to learn all the dancing
stuff and that's a very physical show
there's lots of
two-person dances that involve slamming
each other onto pool tables and doing
roles and yeah it's a very physical show
what what was the thing that i mean can
you mention the oscars walk me through
how you feel you're about to host the
oscars what what do you what is your
bathroom routine what are you saying to
yourself are you looking in the mirror
are you maniacally going over lines what
how do you feel is your stomach hurt
right before the show starts i feel
pretty calm because
it's about to happen it's the dress
rehearsal the day before when you're
running through your jokes and there's
no audience laughing and you've got all
these things planned and you're not sure
how they're going to go that's really
just like that's like that stand up yeah
that's the tricky point i like the
opening numbers i've done the emmys
where it's all tv but the oscars is the
movies so i thought let's do an opening
number that would be inclusive of
technology in movies so there was clip
stuff that was your idea yeah that's
really cool and we did it so i was yeah
i just didn't want anything to go wrong
and weirdly things went wrong but yeah
thankfully he didn't know we got jack
black on there and did not know at all
in fact i remember my my impression of
that is that it was actually quite
successful it was fun um what is the
next thing what i mean you mentioned
this great murder mystery uh movie
you're doing i'm gonna angle towards
directing more i'm doing some
smaller parts in
in interesting feature films that won't
come out like gone girl yeah that was
those kind of things
i love the process justin doing stuff
yeah i love
being in the rehearsal space yeah when
no one's around and trying it i love
previews i love tech me too i love when
there's stunts and and i want to do my
own stunts and wear the wires i don't
want to be in a motor home or whatever
waiting for an a.d to knock on the door
and say they're ready for you right but
i just i don't know i've been very lucky
in not being able to just do a singular
thing well maybe that's why i like sleep
no more so much right because of course
it's a difference when you're in that
show you're not you're doing it you're
living it for a while and i just think
when we can have experiences whether
we're observing them or participating in
them where
you're living it yeah how fun is that
well and that's what and again i'm
obsessed with escape rooms right now oh
do you do the escape noise no i never
have really no no you want to go do one
sometimes sure i'd love to
i'd love to they're so
fun yeah and i have a lot of anxiety
about little i mean just you know being
late for the little things uh i think
i'd give me a tremendous amount of
anxiety but maybe in a fun way in a such
a fun way because the answers are all
around you so you get to do it's like a
big living puzzle right for sure yeah
and you know that there's all these
disparate things and posters and couches
and things you're supposed to look under
and yeah locks and keys and it's so fun
okay yeah you're one of my brain works
you're still playing that's what i mean
you are
the most playful adult i've ever met and
i'm lucky that i'm get to talk to you
and get to know you and um and oh
last thing this may sound morbid but uh
the name of the show is uh
uh life is short and and um when it ends
uh
what would you want your epitaph to read
his book was filled with many many a
chapter as it already has been yeah yeah
you want to have lots of chapters you
don't want it to be a
easy reader book thank you so much thank
you for having me let's make up let's do
it
yeah not bad not bad
[Music]
well so this is the part of the show uh
we like to call
so that happened
so that did happen it did happen oh i
forgot to ask him about his [ __ ]
oh no wait i didn't but we talked i
think enough just enough about [ __ ]
disagreed
you were just scratching the surface
yeah
so to speak not on yours on his i wanted
to hear more about his his immaculate
butthole
well creation said afterwards we
continued the conversation because neil
was genuinely curious about
the grooming habits of straight men and
i felt a little uncomfortable
representing
the whole of straight
um the whole of straight men um
and and i'm now getting self-conscious
that maybe i don't groom enough and uh
and i'm also getting really
self-conscious that my parents are
listening to this
but um
he seems so
together yeah and and impressive in
general as a person yeah he's so
articulate and economical with his words
everything about him screams immaculate
[ __ ]
you know his personality and and the way
his his hair is so he's so uh and he's
in such great shape attention to
personal detail
yeah so the other thing that surprised
me you were talking about how
economically is with his words how
efficient he is um there's something
very sharp there's something his wit is
sharp his uh the way he expresses ideas
yeah he's very precise and i don't mean
that in like a robotic way uh quite the
opposite he's very
you know you know what's interesting
about him is that he is
so
um open-minded i think as a person yeah
yet he's so careful with how he says
things and the words he chooses so it's
a weird kind of juxtaposition you know
usually people who are that careful with
what words they choose tend to be a
little bit more i think uptight maybe
and
kind of aware of their image and wanting
to present a certain thing but i don't
think he is at all i think i think he's
very free and open but yet he's very
precise about the words he chooses i
know that's an interesting combination i
was having the same thought i was like
he never says like and as i'm thinking
this during the interview he says oh
sorry am i saying like too much he
corrected himself because he said like
once yeah i've made me feel like some
like
valley girl
i was like liking that it's like totally
fine um i also really appreciated that
he was honest about his own
flaws that he he was said that he had
kind of watched himself as his
mechanisms his behavior where he reads
reviews reads reviews yeah but he was
honest about
um you know feeling uncomfortable in his
body sometimes we found that that
surprised me about being on a red
carpet saying that he he
doesn't do his hands
if there's anyone that i've ever known i
knew uh
seems like they would never
be at all uncomfortable without being on
a red carpet it's him but that's
surprising i think that speaks to the
the the fact that no but if if neil's
not come from on a red carpet i don't
think it's possible to be totally
uncomfortable unless you're a sociopath
if you're some you got to be a
psychopath to be comfortable at one of
those things yeah you know um but thank
you guys uh for listening i hope you
enjoyed it if you didn't get enough mrs
doubtfire chat please stick around after
the credits uh to hear a
voice memo um of a conversation between
me and christian
talking about mrs doubtfire while we
were
um relaxed a little mrs doubtfire
bookend if you will oh would that be
lovely life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
for listening to life is short if you
like the show please give us five star
review uh on uber and tell your friends
to subscribe we're available on apple
podcast spotify google podcasts every
major listening app life is short is
hosted by me justin long and is produced
by christian long michelle lands
executive produced by marshall louis and
hernan lopez for wondering
[Music]
this is such a long introduction isn't
it
they have too much time to recognize him
he'd be like uh eventually they'd be
like wait a second
[Music]
she's like we're talking they're talking
about the father he's in their
consciousness and they're looking at i
know
you smell like you even smell like my
husband yeah your breath is just like my
husband
you